alors ça c'est là la schl a dit kito
away ouf
j'avoue vous allez rien capté 6
j'explique à kiffer bon moi c'est
lassana hockey et au dos en gros je suis
un genre de super héros enfin plus ou
moins quoi après je vous comme tout de
suite hein je voi pas j'ai pas de force
surhumaine tout ça moi mon pouvoir c'est
que je rêve d'agression ou créer un jour
avant que ça se produit
j'ai pas trop douce à s'armer et chic
dans ma famille a toujours eu des gens
qui rêvent de choses qui vont arriver
mais bon je pourrais pas vraiment ce
qu'est ce que je rêve de l'amour mon
propre père il était chauffeur de taxi
et je suis sûr que j'aurais pu faire
quelque chose aujourd'hui balmont veut
carrément chaque l'euro qui perd
quelqu'un de proche chez mega cliché
mais accrochez-vous parce que j'ai plus
qui chaque sens et quand je vous disais
je vous parle mon meilleur ami farès non
lui crois vraiment qu'on est dans un
film je crois qu'ils s'en vont mais bon
en vérité sans lui arrivera rien quand
même un [ __ ] de fardeaux ce pouvoir
parce qu'après chaque rêve on doit
décortiquer ce que j'ai vu et agir vite
à
et un truc que j'ai pas dis aussi ça à
chaque fois que j'ai une vision que je
prend feu vite fait c'est un peu chiant
aussi mais bon heureusement que c'est
pas tous les jours
et sinon bah comme tous les super héros
il ya un méchant dans mon histoire je
vous présente soldats ces trois d
empiler la plupart des gens que je dois
sauver situe à 6 mois goudé merde parce
qu'ils exploitent les petits du quartier
j'ai vraiment l'impression que la pâte
que [ __ ] je le déteste
voilà vous savez tout merde choqueront
vous ai même pas expliquer ce que je
fous là en gros nous avantager une
vision de semaine frappant sa copine
d'une manière assez violente au point
qu'elle finissait dans commun et grâce à
farès on a trouvé l'e-mail en passant
par le trajet peut atteindre leur balcon
après x était fermée ben j'ai attendu
quoi et maintenant je peux intervenir
mais tout est paul mekla qui filme les
meufs et qui met sur internet
non non non je t'arrête tout pour moi si
si si si la praire du corps ont des gros
je veux pas te laisser frapper demeure
quand même parce que je sais pas me
défendre tout seul genre non j'ai pas
dit ça mais pour comprendre il va aller
trop loin alors comme ça je suis trop
long mais si ces coups six soirs et dire
c'est qui lui
je remets des mecs chez nous pour ma
fille chez extrême qu'est pour tes
courses en magasin
casse toi c'est sa bonne soirée ciao
telle est la situation est sous contrôle
je crois que ferrer bien bon pas de quoi
c'est réglé non je parle pas avec je
parle à mon avis tant en fait atteint
l'assistant et tous atteindre esparros
en fait
bah ouais a pas faibli ronin sans blague
j'ai l'impression que tu savais ce qui
allait se passer avant suffolk nantais
pas folle eh ben on laisse tomber on va
je peux pas te révéler mes secrets pas
vraiment non bref oublie que j'appelle
la police fait jamais qui revient voilà
du coup j'espère qu'ils sont pas sont en
fait je t'explique en vrai moi je viens
et j'interviens je fais en sorte que ça
n'allait pas plus loin mais bon après ça
tient pas qu'à moi c'est à toi d'appeler
la police
c'est leur métier pas le mien tu vois
plus comme ça c'est plus simple et c'est
tout
ouais ouais je crois tu peux rentrer
chez toi
bonne idée en bas bon courage
fais attention à toi gc ca
[Musique]
à
je crois que je vais passer par la porte
[Musique]
d'honneur accompagné dans cette scène sa
mère résiliente chambre des cantons
par contre j'adore pas pas
[Musique]
j'sais pas pourquoi tu vas t'en bien moi
aussi
[Musique]
m
on a eu deux visions en deux jours ce
n'était jamais arrivé sain non je sors
savez j'ai un truc déjà on sait que
c'est dehors et de ce que tu as vu est
démarqué blanche au sol ça peut être un
parking un truc du genre
mais en plus de ça tu as vu 3 2 voilà un
très bon mec parce que même si tu te
tapes bien n'a pas couché trois mecs à
toi tout seul tout ce que je veux dire
vrai prendre devrait sauver des arbres
sérieux ça se ressent qu'armand et c'est
tout elle met ses droits d [ __ ] ça se
trouve m quand vous mettez à sa place en
place c'est pas à nous de réfléchir à ça
si tu peux sauver la personne tu dois le
faire c'est tout sinon tu te retournes
marque que lui et toi t'es pas une merde
t'es le héros de l'histoire
ok mais moi je suis pote géraud super
intelligent et beau gosse attend
normalement ventures pas spécialement
beau baisse n'est etc ont en plus fait
différé même pas marrant ah ouais et le
héros n'est pas sensible chez ses
parents prendre les 4 0 à 6 fin et se
faire tâche par laboeuf qu'il aime 1
c'est grave comme tu lui envoie des
messages elle répond pas
tu fais quoi bébé vue tudor pu j'ai pas
si tu as vu mes derniers messages vue
est toujours vue très rappelle la vue
sur ton répertoire c'est grave quand
même vraiment
je t'aurais fait une dernière et depuis
donc on renvoie non je peux encore ans
je pense pas parce que physiquement tu
es pas ouf
ah ouais physiquement on voit tout de
suite mais y'a pas de soucis je termine
juste mon petit cube gris frérot et
après je trouve toujours des prétextes
c'est un truc d'hommes et severn ans et
de l'appétit au quai de la pallée arrête
de raconter tes rêves bref c'est quoi le
pendre associés super intelligent est
déjà en prennent à la future victime
pour une fois je pense qu'il faut aller
voir cela trouve même quoi attendre 5
mai sauvetage y marche que si
j'interviens juste avant j'ai en plus
dans ma vision et nuit donc possible je
te dis pas d'aller les voir pour le
sauver et peut-être on peut essayer de
savoir où il sera là ce soir là
justement peut tenter un parfait je vais
avec toi parce que chanteuse mais avant
le foot n'était pas très fort
physiquement de rendre ouf
ouais ouais les gars c'est comme moi tu
as bien apple nous par nos prénoms aussi
thèmes plus même si on adore ça bon
alors que tout à coup c'est flatteur
oui et non ce que les dragon ball à la
base c'est pas des personnages c'est
juste des boules de cristal un plus bon
après c'est vrai qu'elle permet
d'invoquer cheron la raison qui permet
des océans
là je me sens en vue pour refus par la
cour a dit tu vois là j'ai rendez-vous a
détaillé la sorte à rester debout c'est
pourtant cartonné terrain a tempéré sont
roulés au moins un
si je te dis qu'on a une recette pour
faire de la m à 99 cents attendu quoi
j'en dis rien et arrêter les gars un qui
croit que vous avez devant vous fait
rire là on est dans la vraie vie
alors un conseil cassez vous avant de
vous casser la bouche
et non
bientôt ce soir de mai a pu stopper
[ __ ] j'y serai 99% c'est pas réaliste
j'aurais dû dire non je savais comme tu
as vu comment ils nous parlent c'est pas
toi c moi 96 à la rigueur ça peut passer
mais 99 c'est trop je sais tranquille on
va trouver une solution une solution qu
il est sûr que tu feras cet [ __ ] quoi
j'ai laissé un numéro d'à côté d'eux on
va pouvoir entendre leur rendez vous
important quoi un regard sur internet tu
verras tu veux faire quoi encore la
squatteuse il est maintenant totale
parle
apparemment ils sont fait livrer des
motocross saison quoi justement il veut
les offrir à des types eu un truc du
genre
[ __ ] merde et entend plus s'éloigne du
prix sont montés dans une voiture ils
vont sûrement récupérer les motocross
très fort pas qu'on lâche l'enquêté
motocross et parking c'est peut-être ça
la piste la plus probable est prêt à
faire c'est bon ton avis pourquoi ils
offrent des cross au pied les exploits
gros et vas-y 10 - un combat qu'on a
arrêté l'école à cause de lui bien
qu'ils le moment je t'ai dit que c'était
bien ça je crois que les trois mecs tout
à l'heure qui vont lui casser la gueule
ils sont mieux que lui d'ailleurs faut
vraiment une grande pour soi permet
quatre au fait c'est quoi
oublie vite on plan déchets pas quoi je
les fais absolument
mais là sont nées les gens sinon on
sauve les gens ont pensé moi qui prend
tous les risques à chaque fois assez
comme ça
ouais c'est comme ça un frère on dirait
ça t'amuse tout ça pour toi qui rêvent
tous les jours du tri des merdes et qui
se réveille avec toute la pression du
monde non c'est vraiment attend ça
n'empêche pas quelque chose qu'on peut
t'aider ah bah écoute la situer medard
de me casser les couilles de soldats
c'est bon je le ferme
ok le message est passé
moi je veux sortir maintenant morte sur
toi même à la victime tu mens foot je
comprends pas à quoi c'est dangereux
d'or notre sort pas c'est quoi ces
profits favre 900 rend pauvre
[Musique]
oui vous jouez c'est ça a laissé
installer vous voilà mettez vous à
l'aise
merci j'entends un petit accent là oui
ça vient d'où sa espagne l'espagne ne se
sent pas ça va vous parler d'eux pour
une espagnole
un merci ces gels a pris un régal un des
séries et des films
ah ouais oui c'est incroyable après le
temps moi aussi c'est vrai que
j'apprends un peu le japonais mais avec
les mangas c'est un peu pareil bah ouais
bah si tu apprends vite il faut que tu
le regardes tes série espagnole ses
proches de français ouais après vos
séries je le trouve un peu claqué quand
même claque et ça veut dire quoi claque
et ça veut dire que ça pue du cul
c'est de la merde quand c'est ça c'est
de la grosse merde comment expliquer la
meilleure a way à l'eau wafa reste assez
bon je sais les marquages au sol c'était
pas un parking c'est au collège en fait
et c'est là-bas que solvay va se faire
soulever cool mais encore ah ouais
excuse pour talât mais encore je pense t
il meilleur associé à un rochus très
simple elle alla j'aime bien j'ai pas
moi allez vas-y le iron man la kabylité
content maintenant à la temouchent rire
oh là là on s'entend bien là c'est bon
j'ai tout de suite j'arrive quand vous
êtes tout de suite cet aprem avoir des
projets à destination
[Musique]
notons [ __ ] de téléphone jacques as
you
[Musique]
mais mettez à tête mais vous allez où
c'est pas par là non il ya un truc il
faut que je montre toi aux faucons à y
circuler monsieur circuler et deux
étoiles sur mes petits-fils de plus j'ai
tout fait mais ta gueule va me bats toi
tu t'ouvres continuer à frapper
il sait ce que je vois la ferme ta
gueule qui veut pas que kate moss à 103
dans les histoires de super-héros
c'est tellement facile de savoir qui
sont les méchants qui sont les gentils
et dans la vraie vie c'est pau 6 ans
j'étais complètement perdue mais
[Musique]
qu'est ce tu perds
pensé que j'étais foutu aussi bas non
parce que farès encore lui a réussi à
prévenir toute la cité sans parler de la
touriste espagnole qui était pas là pour
blaguer
bref du coup les condéens ont pas eu
d'autre choix que de partir
et là les gens ont commencé à m'appeler
j'ai vraiment eu l'impression d'être air
[Musique]
et finalement je me suis surtout rendu
compte que j'avais passé trop de temps
essayé d'être un bon super héros
pas assez de temps être un bon être
humain
[Musique]
à